MIT is a very fun place to be at.
I am Yoruba.
That's the tribe in Nigeria that I'm from, and our language is very rhythmic.
It's very tonal.
And here there's a group called Rambax.
It's a Senegalese drum ensemble.
It's an education in the type of culture...
...that you find in very many places on the continent.
I took it as a class, and just the rhythms and the beats...
...and the presence of everybody learning the same bax together,...
...nobody drums in isolation.
Right?
You're always looking at the person beside you...
...because you're trying to stay in rhythm,...
...and I saw this also in lab projects with other peers.
There's this sense that you check in with everybody around you...
...as a community, as a team,...
...and make sure that you're all moving towards your goal together.